what is a scene
a scene is like one step toward the
bigger picture so in the scene you're
looking at who wants what and what is
getting in the way
who wants what what is getting in the
way how do you create
the small piece of the bigger puzzle
through looking at the scene and also
understanding what is the conflict in
the scene is
a struggle that I see a lot of writers
go through you often will find scenes
that have no conflict and you have no
sense of who wants what and what is
getting in the way so by simply
understanding the scene as a part of the
greater picture and how you are creating
a step toward an outcome
while escalating the conflict is an
important part of scene work what
happens in a good scene
a good scene is a strategic approach to
how does the scene serve the purpose of
advancing the external plot as well as
the internal with the character
development
so a good scene brings us into the
personal so that we feel the personal as
well as understanding how it's a step in
the external plot what do a lot of new
writers get wrong when they write scenes
I would say the biggest thing that I see
writers get wrong with certain scenes is
they forget
that they're I remember I Came Upon
three things that I thought about should
be in the scene and the idea is the
desire the conflict and the the conflict
being the flaw so so when
so you're looking at the want the
conflict and the why
as a part of a scene and when you have a
scene where we lose sight of what does
the character want what is the main goal
and we and we don't feel it in the scene
that is probably one of the biggest
mistakes I see Maine when I get halfway
through a script and I look at a scene
because I'm feeling lost because I lost
the why the want and the conflict with
the flaw
so there's no there's no filler scenes
in movies where those elements don't
exist within each one like there has to
be that to move the story along
there's value if there's that I think
that you can as we talked about rule
breaking I think you can always find a
way
to it like voice trumps a lot of the
rules if we feel the voice in a scene
and yet there is one of the three
components I mentioned missing
then the voice can make a difference and
if we understand how that scene is a
part of the bigger puzzle and understand
the intention of the writer within that
then again you can look at rules and say
the writer was able to communicate a
message without having to have specific
things
if you look at let's say uh sideways I
know it goes a few years back but it
seems like in every scene miles is is in
a dilemma with himself
really yeah because he feels so
inadequate whether he wants to blame
others for it but he he's always it's
something relates to that he's being
slighted somehow yes well that's because
of the flaw work and uh the flaw that we
feel stemming from the wounds that we're
feeling a part of it from the beginning
and how there there's an escalation of
that but
also not feeling in that movie that
would there's a full understanding of
the want
in a way
that is transformative with the
character like looking at the want and
going all right what specifically does
this character want and how the sideway
Pursuit is bringing the character to
that point uh in that character you if I
remember correctly and it's God it's
been so long since I've seen that film
but that film really resonated certainly
from someone who's been through divorce
someone who knows what pain looks like
and what the healing process looks like
I feel like that was a film that
everyone identified with and certainly
the whole Merlot aspect of the wine
industry and all that like it stays with
you and you remember that character
because of of the wound and the flaw
work and and looking at
the trans information
within it that story has stayed with me
so so that that is that is a good
example of of looking at at it in the
way that you're talking about
right because it seems like there were
no really useless scenes in that film
whatsoever everything set something up
where Miles was going to somehow feel
badly about himself yes and luckily he
had this other component which was the
Thomas Hayden Church character who felt
so incredible about himself to remind
him of how how low he was so it was
there was always this tension of here
was this person on a pedestal and here
was Miles yes and it was it was a
wonderful and what you tapped into
that's so good there is polarity when
you have polarity in story and you have
one character who's weak where the other
is strong and vice versa then again
that's something very Universal in life
polarity is another thing for me like
dilemma where there was this massive Aha
and sideways is an excellent example of
looking at how polarity adds so much
depth to story and to character
transformation
what does it mean to start a scene late
and leave early
to start a seeing late means your
audience could feel stuck with how the
scene is fitting into the overall
picture and to end it early there is a
term called the button of a scene where
we feel the button at the end of the
scene that's in the overall meaning of
of the story so you you also want to
look at scenes as in another respect
that I thought about in in talking about
this is your scenes should always set up
where your character is going to next so
another mistake that writers make in
scenes is we should never arrive in a
scene and not know how we got there
interesting I'm thinking of um Sophie's
Choice yes and one of the many
incredible scenes in the film is where
the Kevin Klein character arrives home
late yes and and finds her drinking with
the the neighbor and and just just sort
of the the the the tension in the room
and so I guess we
it's been a little bit since I've seen
it but just just how those scenes were
set up because there was always like a
weird implication of something we didn't
know totally what it was we didn't know
what Sophie was we knew something she
was dealing with we didn't know
everything you didn't know everything
and that's where scene work comes in
handy as far as the whole linking aspect
I remember another thing that I remember
uh from Jeffrey kitchen was the idea and
I learned this at the beginning of my
career as an executive take a script
from the back to the front and make sure
that every preceding scene sets up the
next scene
and it was a great tool so easy like it
still stands in my mind and when I
covered procedurals as a current
executive it particularly came into play
of oh my gosh that I get that that's
something that stays and I and and there
there are so many scenes where you're
like how did we get here what is this I
didn't feel the setup and because you
didn't feel the setup it's because the
writer didn't do the setup and and the
significance of setting up where the
character is going next or having a
puzzle as you're mentioning that we
understand
how it fits the greater picture and if
we don't understand
then that comes down to the writing and
even for time lapses let's say I realize
every scene is usually involves a time
lapse but like a major yearly or decade
time lapse
yeah how are we how are we playing with
the scene and that we're tying them
together I think the time lapses are
interruptive like the flashbacks so you
need to know when you are going to have
a time lapse how that affects the
overall goal like if in the middle of a
script you have a 10-year jump then
you're going well how does that affect
the initial goal
I remember there was a show that I think
in editing they probably shifted it if
if I remember correctly I think I read
an article on it there was a show called
the night manager with Hugh Laurie where
they did do in the middle of the pilot
episode they did a time Jump
however the rule the the goal remained
the same because the goal still had to
do with bringing the Arms Dealer down
so that was a time Jump that worked so I
always think when you're doing time
jumps
is it needs to have a strategy just like
your Arc of growth has a strategy just
like your story arc has a strategy your
time Jump can't take us out of where we
feel the main plot is going we need to
understand how the time Jump factors in
to the goal